le théâtre des arènes qui doit
accueillir le nouveau spectacle gallo
romain est comme neuf pas vrai
ça vole pas vrai on peut ce match aller
face à ça voilà notre salle
quasi définitive frédéric n'a pas trop
le temps de s'extasier une armée de
jeunes gens est déjà en train de prendre
la place de ses ouvriers
ce sont les danseurs ou les vingt-deux
artistes ne dispose plus que de trois
jours pour prendre leurs repères sur
scène
pourtant le parc a beaucoup investi dans
ce nouveau spectacle pour dynamiser la
saison 2 millions d'euros très
exactement
david est l'un des metteurs en scène du
nouveau spectacle
installé à la place des visiteurs il
observe l'ajustement des nouvelles
cascades de très très près
on va faire
[Musique]
clin d'oeil à l'humour de goscinny
oblige le spectacle est basé sur un
anachronisme
il représentera une bataille rangée en
costume entre gaulois et romains à coups
de pas de danse hip hop pas encore super
calé il va falloir que
nan mais franchement ça grogne un peu
d'autres artistes sont susceptibles de
grenier
pour ses 50 ans idéfix est à l'honneur
dans le spectacle le petit chien aura la
lourde tâche de training gourde de
potion magique pesant tout de même un
quart de son poids alors à chaque
passage
le comédien lui donne discrètement une
récompense
vous donnez pas bien rétabli
[Musique]
comme ça les motive et il lui a donné
corps à ça les magiciens de ne pas leur
secret
non j'ai trié en dise et pour ne pas
qu'ils grossissent trop mais surtout
qu'il ne s'épuise idée fixe n'a pas une
mais deux ou plus alors les filles deux
petits ou plutôt petit westin darling et
djerba on les traite comme des stars ce
sont nos stars sosie officiel d'idéfix
au cinéma djerba et darling pâture luret
pour l'occasion devront comme tous les
artistes assuré le spectacle
quatre fois par jour on a dû apprendre à
supporter le harnais déjà avec lavrov
derrière parce que comme elle se met à
courir
la gourde traîne derrière donc c'est pas
naturel peau ouais voilà plus que ça
devait mécanisée en fait de répéter
répéter mais la véritable star du show
cet ange et dick
juché à deux mètres cinquante du sol
elle jouera les arbitres de la bataille
entre gaulois et romains
deux équipes de quatre combattants vont
selon des épreuves extrêmes
la victoire sera acquise au plus grand
nombre de points et de moi
la comédienne s'apprête à vivre sa
sixième saison sur le parc
pour l'instant on ne s'en rend pas bien
compte mais elle interprétera une diva
aux tenues extravagantes tenue qui elles
aussi sont loin d'être prêtes
allez tu vas nous faire un petit
essayages cet après midi angélique a
rendez vous avec isabelle la chef
costumière pour la première fois elle va
enfiler sa tenue principal de diva une
diva de bric et de broc
alors le truc c'est que je pense que là
c'est un peu trop long je pense que ce
morceau là est plus relevé que celui ci
ouais mais tu sais quand on n'est pas
égaux à moi non pas tout
tout le monde est dur non mais tu sais
tu as jamais les éponges devrait donc on
va essayer après 2 le vrille et un peu
comme ça donc là c'est la technique
système d un centre en quelques secondes
isabelle a rendu à la diva de sa superbe
nan mais c'est nickel angélique découvre
son personnage pour la première fois là
c'est sûr que c'est pas un personnage
discret donc voilà il faut prendre de
l'espace dans le jeu dans la voix dans
le corps tu es la diva est vraiment une
diva ils sont partis sur le côté ce
testing star la star va porter cinq
costumes différents fabriqué avec les
tissus chine et au marché saint-pierre
entre les matières et la conception ce
sont les plus coûteux du spectacle
jusqu'à 2000 euros pièce car sincèrement
du sur mesure 1 personne d'autre paul m
c'est vraiment pour elle assez fou on
dirait carrément aller au bout d'un
tunnel et les trucs en acier et or
[Musique]
j'adore cette équipe et ces postes
c'est rigolo c'est vrai c'est un côté un
petit peu défilé tu vois que tu as fait
un petit peu contemporain non mais elle
est un peu dingo l'aide qu'on voit là
elle est dingue howlett c'est exactement
ça enfin quoi voir les costumes qu'on a
imaginé conçu de rien de de papier quoi
il a bel et survoltée elle en oublierait
presque que les accessoires eux sont
encore en mousse spéciale pour thuram
les couturières n'ont plus que trois
jours pour que la magie opère
ne lâche rien même si c'est la dernière
ligne droite et qu'effectivement on est
prise par le temps on est on essaie
vraiment de tirer au plus haut plus haut
quoi
mais ils démarrent dans 20 minutes il ya
déjà des gens qui font la queue
d'ailleurs on va falloir qu'on organise
ça pour pas que ça déborde trop sur la
place j'ai vous demander de vous mettre
un tout petit peu sur le côté s'il vous
plaît ça va commencer dans à la demi
minute vingt minutes voilà
et vingt minutes avant le début des
hostilités
en coulisses les artistes se préparent
si tu fais un été dans sa loge
angélique la comédienne est déjà bien
dans son rôle de diva j'aime bien c'est
un moment de détente mais c'est bien les
équipes se préparent depuis des mois
pour cette première la première d'une
longue série
pendant huit mois ils vont jouer devant
près de 4000 personnes chaque jour
quand on arrive au moment de la fin des
répétitions pour va passer au moment des
spectacles à ces moments le plus plus
excitant quand même stressant évidemment
parce qu'on va on va se confronter au
public
mais voilà on sait on a travaillé pour
ça donc on en présente enfin un petit
cadeau une heure est nécessaire avant
chaque représentation pour métamorphoser
angélique pour les tenues et perruques
la comédienne va devoir jongler en
direct entre chaque scène durant le
spectacle
comme ça tu vas être tous à la tuque
c'est vrai plus à la taille mais par
encore à la fota ouais dix minutes avant
d'entrer en scène
angélique s'isole dans le calme dans la
loge d'à côté en revanche les huit
combattants hip hop sont surexcités
un petit coup de laque et les gaulois
ont l'air d'avoir parfaitement adopté
leur nouveau look
[Musique]
oui c'est vrai la bigote nouvelle
moustache
je viens très saignant brushing et les
romains ont raison de s'équiper
car leurs adversaires sont prêts à
distribuer des baffes c'est parti
quelques loges plus loin une autre star
se concentre sur son rôle
la gc les moustaches bauloise ya pas de
raison qu elle ait pas de moustache idée
fixe mais déjà dehors les portes
s'ouvrent le spectacle commence dans
cinq minutes
les gradins de la reine se remplissent
les équipes attendent beaucoup des
réactions du public si le show plaît
cela devrait assurer le succès de la
saison
[Musique]
c'est justice est sur ton entrée la
vente pour la bagarre à la fin tu
reviens dans l'énergie qu'est ce qui se
passe et après place toi pour me david
le metteur en scène va se fondre dans le
public pour visualiser les détails des
chorégraphies
sa position
en coulisses angélique est enfin devenue
la diva
dernier détail la fameuse coiffe en
polystyrène devenu un casque d'or et là
je baille c'est ma façon à moi de voir
le trek 13e
[Musique]
angélique est censé faire une entrée
spectaculaire en s'élevant à plusieurs
mètres du sol mais son ascension va être
beaucoup moins spectaculaire que prévu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça démarre mal et les couacs vont
s'enchaîner durant les 25 minutes de
spectacle
[Applaudissements]
tu es le début du combat
la formation romaine se désole
les gaulois fred davantage jusqu'à cette
pirouette ou l'un des danseurs perd sa
perruque
la bataille se trouve suis dans un flou
capillaire artistique cas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de retour en coulisses les artistes
refont le match est rythmé son côté pour
le battage et
j'étais dans le tram est un peu mitigé
c'était des décalages mais sans les
chorégraphies à 2 donc du coup max et il
fait là résultats gaulois romains
ex-aequo alors qu'il souffle angélique
elle court en rallye
[Musique]
toutes les cinq minutes la comédienne
doit changer de tenue et de perruques
[Musique]
mais ces arrêts aux stands n'ont pas
tous été bien programmé
on n'a pas de perruque hier partout
néanmoins dans l'arène le spectacle
continue
personne ne soupçonne qu'en coulisses
angélique s'arrachent les cheveux
[Musique]
derrière la diva entre pour la cinquième
fois sur scène pour annoncer le clou du
spectacle
[Musique]
c'est en effet le fou coqueluche du parc
qui clôture le show en beauté
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le public semble conquis mais les
artistes ont un regard très critique sur
leur première balle malheureusement
c'est pas passé parfaitement
techniquement la toute première rentrée
d'être à deux mètres cinquante du sol je
devais être un 40 cm voilà l'effet d'un
petit peu un petit peu moins fort on va
dire seulement quelques orteils
ça c'est partir du spectacle vivant donc
il est français qu'il y ait des petits
problèmes mais le but c'est de les
résoudre au plus vite et que le public
ne semble pas qu'on ait les jeunes
visiteurs semblent en effet totalement
insensible à ces détails
démarrant oui j'aime bien les baulois
j'aime bien des amis
il est trop mignon